alors françois audet directeur de
l'observatoire canadien sur les crises
et l'aide humanitaire bonsoir à vous
comment les gens regardent les
schaeffler se disent peut-être c'est pas
si mal qu'elle re a fait sa part 7e sur
la planète
vous vous dites au contraire on baise
année après année oui ben en fait de
deux façons ont d'une part je pense que
globalement si on les chiffres
démontrent qu'on atteint un peu les
objectifs qu'on se dit dès le départ
mais ces objectifs-là de départ qui ne
sont pas très élevés ou paul vi du tout
surtout dans la situation de ce qu'on
appelle la crise des migrants
actuellement il ya aujourd'hui deux
millions de migrants en turquie en
attente de passer en europe ou d'espoir
maintenir en amérique du nord 1 millions
deux millions
en libye c'est 1.5 million de personnes
et à travers ça traverse dans le sahel
enfin le moyen-orient il ya plusieurs
autres centaines de milliers de
personnes qui sont en transit
actuellement donc ce sont des millions
de personnes qui pour des raisons
demande de sécurité 80% d'entre eux
c'est parce qu'il quitte la guerre il ya
peu près 20% pour des raisons
économiques mais 80% ont un statut qu'on
appelle donc de réfugiés et selon ce que
le reportage que vous venez tirer est
vrai on a signé des accords qui font en
sorte que on doit recevoir des réfugiés
on ne peut pas refouler des réfugiés de
fondement daz évidemment qui répondent à
des considérations ça va de soi et que
mich en faites ce que je dis c'est que
les chiffres ou préalables sont beaucoup
trop bas par rapport à la crise mondiale
ou qu'elles ont fait face aujourd'hui
pour mettre en perspective je veux quand
même montré un tableau qui montre donc
cette baise année après année et eu des
petits sursauts on va le voir on a des
chiffres depuis 2004 jusqu'en 2014 alors
vous le voyez assez bien cette année 23
1277 demande acceptée et il ya eu des
bons de 1432
les chiffres parlent d'eux mêmes ah
c'est ce que vous dénoncez vous d'autant
plus que nous sommes dans un contexte de
crise voilà puis si on avait reculé dans
le temps encore plus depuis 1990 enfants
on est en baisse importante
on a eu des demandes d'aidé
nombre de réfugiés beaucoup plus
important par le passé donc un nombre
qui descendent des besoins qui
augmentent et surtout une politique d'
aide aux réfugiés qui est une politique
de refoulement parce que parallèlement à
la baisse du nombre d'entrées ici on
augmente les financements ou haut
commissariat aux réfugiés
donc l organisation qui gère les
réfugiés sur le terrain puisque
finalement encourage les populations à
rester dans les situations de conflit ou
surtout dans les situations de camps de
réfugiés qui évidemment un des pires
situations au monde et il ya des
millions de personnes actuellement qui
vivent dans des camps de réfugiés qui
n'ont pas d'identité qui n'ont pas accès
à rien le nom de réfugiés syriens vont
voir un autre tableau avec s'il vous
plaît réfugié au canada on le 23 mai
mais le nombre de syriens réfugiés
depuis début de la crise et 2374 aller
voir apparaître à l'écran on avait dit
d'e-mails là n'est pas finie vous allez
me dire dont on a eu que deux mille
trois cents c'est peut-être le chiffre
qui parle plus aujourd'hui dans la
mesure où ça montre qu'on n'a pas ouvert
les portes seulement n'a pas facilité on
n'a pas mis de l'huile dans l'engrenage
et la tante du petit allen cordy le
disait bien moi je ne mendie ça peut
marcher prendre mes frères pour l'autre
de mes frères c'est trop compliqué j'ai
envoyé une lettre au ministre n'a rien
donné
c'est cela qui fait mal aujourd'hui
tout à fait puis en fait un chiffre de
l'ordre de 10 minutes c'est trop peu le
canada par rapport à sa capacité
d'accueil par rapport aux c'est ce que
les pays d'europe et les etats unis sont
capables de recevoir
on devrait plutôt parler de l'ordre de
cent mille réfugiés syriens
étant donné l'ampleur l'on parle de 4
millions de personnes qui attendent aux
frontières de la syrie et ce chiffre là
et il vient notamment du ccr qui
effectivement déclare en fonction de la
capacité d'accueil des pays à peu près
le nombre de réfugiés qu'on serait
capable de recevoir dont 10 mais elle
est vraiment trop peu étant donné
l'ampleur de la crise actuellement vous
l'avez dit un peu mais je veux qu'on
conclut là dessus dans l'histoire le
canada comme les autres pays mais a déjà
ouvert ses portes de façon beaucoup plus
efficace on pense aux boat people on
remonte dans les années 70 lui la crise
angolaise également il y a eu des
exemples où là on y allait plus
roulement des cas extraordinaires qui
ont fait en sorte que estimant qu' on a
ouvert nos portes de manière plus
importante
où on a probablement mis un peu plus
d'huile dans la bureaucratie aujourd'hui
notre bureaucratie stature
l'administration publique qui gère ces
demandes là utilisent les mêmes
pratiques et même politique sport que
les gens sont moins efficaces mais une
petite semaine pratique selon les
règlements de la deuxième guerre
mondiale et de la guerre froide
on n'est plus dans ce monde là ça
n'existe plus faut absolument qu'on
réagisse nos manières de voir les
qualifications des demandes d'exil il se
met à jour vis à vis et c'est clair qu
actuellement le 2300 sur le 10 mai au
total démontre qu'il ya des goulots
d'étranglement ou carrément d'un désir
significatif qu on ne veut pas recevoir
ces réfugiés syriens
françois houdé merci beaucoup